The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: I want to take a few
minutes at the start of
today's lecture to wrap
up a few more
things about debugging.
And then I'll move on
to the main event.
Just a few small points.
First of all, keep in mind that
the bug is probably not
where you think it is.
Because if a bug were there,
you'd have already found it.
There are some simple things
that you should always look at
when you're looking for bugs.
Reversed order of arguments.
You might have a function that
takes to floats and you just
passed them in the
wrong order.
You may have noticed that when
Professor Grimson and I used
examples in class, we were
pretty careful how we name our
parameters.
And I often end up using the
same names for the actuals and
the formals.
And this just helps me not get
confused about what order to
do things in.
Spelling.
These are just dumb little
things to look for.
Did you spell all the
identifiers the way
you think you did.
The problem is, when you
read code you see what
you expect to see.
And if you've typed in l when
you should've typed a 1, or a
1 when you should've typed an
l, you're likely to miss it.
If you've made a mistake with
upper and lower case.
Things like that.
So just be very careful
looking at that.
Initialization.
A very common bug is to
initialize a variable.
Go through a loop, and then
forget to reinitialize it when
it needs to be reinitialized
again.
So it's initialized outside
the loop when it should be
initialized inside the loop.
Or conversely, inside the
loop when it should
be outside the loop.
So look carefully at when
variables are being
initialized.
Object versus value equality.
Particularly when you use double
equals, are you asking
whether you've got the same
object or the same value?
They mean very different things,
as we have seen.
Keep track of that.
Related to that is aliasing.
And you'll see that, by the way,
on the problem set that
we're posting tomorrow.
Where we're going to ask you
to just look at some code,
that there's some issues there
with the fact that you alias
things, maybe on purpose,
maybe on accident.
And by that I mean two different
ways to get to the
same value, the same object.
Frequently that introduces
bugs into the program.
A particular instance of that
is deep versus shallow copy.
When you decide to make a copy
of something like a list, you
have to think hard about are you
only copying the top level
of the list, but if it's, say,
a list that contains a list,
are you also getting
a new copy of
everything it contains?
It doesn't matter if it's a list
of integers or a list of
strings or a list of tuples, but
it matters a lot if it's a
list of lists.
Or a list of anything that
could be mutable.
So when you copy, what
are you getting?
When you copy a dictionary,
for example.
Think through all of that.
And again, a related problem
that people run into is
side-effects.
You call a function and it
returns a value, but maybe it,
on purpose or on accident,
modifies one of the actual
parameters.
So you could each make
a list of things.
Every experienced programmer
over time develops a personal
model of the mistakes
they make.
I know the kinds of things
I get wrong.
And so when I'm looking for a
bug, I always say, oh, have
you done this dumb thing
you always do.
So be a little bit
introspective.
Keep track of the mistakes
you make.
And if your program doesn't
work, that should be your
first guess.
Couple of other hints.
Keep a record of what
you've tried.
People will look at things and
they'll come in and that'll
talk to a TA, and the TA will
say, did you try this?
And the person will
say, I don't know.
That leads you to end up
doing the same thing
over and over again.
This gets back to my main theme
of Tuesday, which is be
systematic.
Know what you've already tried,
don't waste your time
trying it again.
Think about reconsidering
your assumptions.
A huge one is, are you actually
running the code
you're looking at
in your editor.
This is a mistake I make
all the time in Python.
I sit there in idle, and
I edit some code.
I then click on the shell,
rather than hitting F5, try
and run it and say, it's
not doing what I
thought I should do.
And I'll sit there staring at
the output, staring at the
code, not realizing that
that output was not
produced by that code.
It's a mistake I've learned
that I make.
It's an easy one to
make in Python.
Lots of assumptions like that.
You thought you knew what the
built-in function sort did,
method sort did.
Well, does it do what
you think it does?
Does append do what
Go back and say, alright,
I've obviously, some
assumption is not right.
When you're debugging somebody
else's code, debug the code,
not the comments.
I've often made the mistake
of believing the comments
somebody wrote in your code
about what some function does.
Sometimes it's good
to believe it.
But sometimes you
have to read it.
Important thing.
When it gets really
tough, get help.
Swallow your pride.
Any one of my graduate students
will tell you that
from time to time I walk into
their office and say, do you
have a minute?
And if they foolishly say yes,
I drag them back to my office
and say I'm stuck on this bug,
what am I doing wrong?
And it's amazing what -- well,
a, they're smarter than I am
which helps.
But even if they weren't smarter
than I am, just a
fresh set of eyes.
I've read through the same thing
twenty times and I've
missed something obvious.
Someone who's never seen it
before looks at and says, did
you really mean to do this?
Are you sure you didn't want to
do for i in range of list,
rather than for i in list?
That sort of thing.
Makes a big difference to just
get that set of eyes.
And in particular, try and
explain to somebody else what
you think the program
is doing.
So I'll sit there with the
student and I'll say, I'm
going to try and explain to
you why what I think this
program is doing.
And probably 80% of the time,
halfway through my
explanation, I say,
oh, never mind.
I'm embarrassed.
And I send them away.
Because just the act of
explaining it to him or her
has helped me understand it.
So when you're really stuck,
just get somebody.
And try and explain to them why
you think your program is
doing what it's doing.
Another good thing to do
when you're really
stuck is walk away.
Take a break.
Come back and look at it with
fresh eyes of your own.
Effectively, what you're doing
here is perhaps trading
latency for efficiency.
It may, if you go back, come
back and two hours later,
maybe you'll, it'll take you
at least two hours to have
found the bugs, because you've
been away for two hours.
And maybe if you'd stayed there
and worked really hard
you'd have found it an hour
and fifty eight minutes.
But is it really worth
the two minutes?
This is another reason, by
the way, to start it
long before it's due.
That you actually have the
leisure to walk away.
All right.
What do you do when you've
found the bug and
you need to fix it?
Remember the old saw,
haste makes waste.
I don't know this but I'll bet
Benjamin Franklin said this.
Don't rush into anything.
Think about the fix, don't make
the first change that
comes to mind and
see if it works.
Ask yourself, will it fix all
of the symptoms you've seen?
Or if not, are the symptoms
independent, will at least fix
some of them?
What are the ramifications
of the proposed change.
Will it break other things?
That's a big issue.
You can fix one thing, you
break something else.
So think through what this
change might break.
Does it allow you to tidy
up other things?
This is important, I
think, that code
should not always grow.
We all have a tendency to
fix code by adding code.
And the program just gets bigger
and bigger and bigger.
The more code you have, the
harder it is to get it right.
So, sometimes, what you need
to, so you just pull back.
And say, well, let me
just tidy things up.
That, by the way, is also
a good debugging tool.
Sometimes when I'm really stuck,
I say, alright let me
stop looking for the bug.
Let me just clean up the
code a little bit.
Make my program prettier.
And in the process of tidying it
up and making it prettier,
I'll often by accident
find the bug.
So it's a good trick
to remember.
Finally, and this is very
important, make sure that you
can revert.
There's nothing more frustrating
then spending four
hours debugging, and realizing
at the end of four hours your
program is worse than it
was when you started.
And you can't get back to where
it was when you started.
So if you look at one of my
directories, you'll find that
I've been pretty anal about
saving old versions.
I can always pretty much get
back to some place I've been.
So if I've made a set of changes
and I realize I've
broken something that used to
work, I can find a version of
the code in which it used to
work, and figure out what was
going on there.
Disk space is cheap.
Don't hesitate to save
your old versions.
It's a good thing.
Alright, that's the end of my,
maybe sermon is the right word
on debugging.
Polemic, I don't know.
I hope it will be helpful.
And I hope you'll remember some
of these things as you
try and get your programs
to work.
I now want to get back to
algorithms. And where we've
sort of been for a while,
and where we
will stay for a while.
More fundamentally, I want to
get back to what I think of as
the main theme of 6.00, which
is taking a problem and
finding some way to formulate
the problem so that we can use
computing to help us
get an answer.
And in particular, we're going
to spend the next few lectures
looking at a class of problems
known as optimization
problems. In general,
every optimization
problem is the same.
It has two parts.
Some function that you're either
attempting to maximize
or minimize the value of.
And these are duals.
And some set of constraints
that must be honored.
Possibly an empty set
of constraints.
So what are some of the classic
optimization problems?
Well one of the most well-known
is the so-called
shortest path problem.
Probably almost every one
of you has used a
shortest path algorithm.
For example, if you go to
Mapquest, or Google Maps and
ask how do I get from
here to there.
You give it the function,
probably in this case to
minimize, and it gives you
a choice of functions.
Minimize time, minimize
distance.
And maybe you give it a
set of constraints.
I don't want to drive
on highways.
And it tries to find the
shortest way, subject to those
constraints, to get from Point
A to Point B. And there are
many, many other instances
of this kind of thing.
And tomorrow it's recitation,
we'll spend quite a bit of
time on shortest
path problems.
Another classic optimization
problem is
the traveling salesman.
Actually, I should probably,
be modern, call it the
traveling salesperson, the
traveling salesperson problem.
So the problem here, roughly, is
given, a number of cities,
and say the cost of traveling
from city to city by airplane,
what's the least cost round
trip that you can find?
So you start at one place, you
have to go to a number of
other places.
End up where you started.
It's not quite the same as the
shortest path, and figure out
the way to do that
that involves
spending the least money.
Or the least time, or
something else.
What are some of the other
classic optimization problems?
There's bin packing.
Filling up some container with
objects of varying size and,
perhaps, shape.
So you've got the trunk of
your car and you've got a
bunch of luggage.
More luggage than can
actually fit in.
And you're trying to figure
out what order
to put things in.
And which ones you can put in.
How to fill up that bin.
Very important in shipping.
People use bin packing
algorithms to figure out, for
example, how to load
up container ships.
Things of that nature.
Moving vans, all sorts of
things of that nature.
In biology and in natural
language processing and many
other things, we see a lot of
sequence alignment problems.
For example, aligning DNA
sequences, or RNA sequences.
And, one we'll spend a fair
amount of time on today and
Tuesday is the knapsack
problem.
In the old days people used to
call backpacks knapsacks.
So we old folks sometimes even
still make that mistake.
And the problem there is, you've
got a bunch of things.
More than will fit into the
knapsack, and you're trying to
figure out which things to
take and which things to
leave. As you plan
your hiking trip.
How much water should
you take.
How many blankets?
How much food?
And you're trying to optimize
the value of the objects you
can take subject to the
constraint that the backpack
is of finite size.
Now, why am I telling
you all of this at
this lightning speed?
It's because I want you to think
about it, going forward,
about the issue of problem
reduction.
We'll come back to this.
What this basically means is,
you're given some problem to
solve, that you've never
seen before.
And the first thing you do is
ask is it an instance of some
problem that other people
have already solved?
So when the folks at Mapquest
sat down to do their program,
I guarantee you somebody opened
an algorithms book and
said, what have other
people done to solve
shortest path problems?
I'll rely on fifty years of
clever people rather than
trying to invent my own.
And so frequently what we try
and do is, we take a new
problem and map it onto an old
problem so that we can use an
old solution.
In order to be able to do that,
it's nice to have in our
heads an inventory of previously
solved problems. To
which we can reduce the
current problem.
So as we go through this
semester, we'll look at,
briefly or not so briefly,
different previously solved
problems in the hope that at
some time in your future, when
you have a problem to deal
with, you'll say, I know
that's really like
shortest path, or
really like graph coloring.
Let me just take my problem and
turn it into that problem,
and use an existing solution.
So we'll start looking in detail
at one problem, and
that's the knapsack problem.
Let's see.
Where do I want to start?
Oh yes, OK.
So far, we've been looking
at problems that
have pretty fast solutions.
Most optimization problems do
not have fast solutions.
That is to say, when you're
dealing with a large set of
things, it takes a while to
get the right answer.
Consequently, you have to
be clever about it.
Typically up till now, we've
looked at things that can be
done in sublinear time.
Or, at worst, polynomial time.
We'll now look at a problem that
does not fall into that.
And we'll start with
what's called the
continuous knapsack problem.
So here's the classic
formulation.
Assume that you are a burglar.
And you have a backpack that
holds, say, eight pounds'
worth of stuff.
And you've now broken into a
house and you're trying to
decide what to take.
Well, let's assume in the
continuous world, what you is
you walk into the house and you
see something like four
pounds of gold dust. And you
see three pounds of silver
dust, and maybe ten
pounds of raisins.
And I don't actually
know the periodic
table entry for raisins.
So I'll have to write it out.
Well, how would you solve
this problem?
First, let's say, what
is the problem?
How can we formulate it?
Well, let's assume that what
we want to do is, we have
something we want to optimize.
So we're looking for
a function to
maximize, in this case.
What might that function be?
Well, let's say it's some number
of, some amount of, the
cost of the value of gold.
Times however many
pounds of gold.
Plus the cost of silver times
however many - no, gold, is a
g, isn't it.
Pounds of silver, plus the
cost of raisins times the
number of pounds of raisins.
So that's the function
I want to optimize.
I want to maximize
that function.
And the constraint is what?
It's that the pounds of gold
plus the pounds of silver plus
the pounds of raisins is
no greater than eight.
So I've got a function to
maximize and a constraint that
must be obeyed.
Now, the strategy here
is pretty clear.
As often is for the continuous
problem.
What's the strategy?
I pour in the gold till
I run out of gold.
I pour in the silver until
I run out of silver.
And then I take as many raisins
as will fit in and I
leave. Right?
I hope almost every one of you
could figure out that was the
right strategy.
If not, you're not well suited
to a life of crime.
What I just described is an
instance of a greedy algorithm.
In a greedy algorithm, at
every step you do what
maximizes your value
at that step.
So there's no planning ahead.
You just do what's ever best.
It's like when someone gets
their food and they start
by eating dessert.
Just to make sure they
get to the best part
before they're full.
In this case, a greedy algorithm
actually gives us
the best possible solution.
That's not always so.
Now, you've actually all
implemented a greedy algorithm.
Or are in the process thereof.
Where have we implemented a
greedy algorithm, or have been
asked to do a greedy
algorithm?
Well, there are not that many
things you guys have been
working on this semester.
Yeah?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Exactly right.
So what you were doing there,
it was a really good throw.
But it was a really good answer
you gave. So I'll
forgive you the bad hands.
You were asked to choose
the word that gave
you the maximum value.
And then do it again with
whatever letters you had left.
Was that guaranteed to win?
To give you the best
possible scores?
No.
Suppose, for example, you had
the letters this, doglets.
Well, the highest scoring word
might have been something like
Doges, these guys used to rule
Venice, but if you did that
you'd been left with the letters
l and t, which are
kind of hard to use.
So you've optimized
the first step.
But now you're stuck
with something
that's not very useful.
Whereas in fact, maybe you would
have been better to go
with dog, dogs, and let.
So what we see here is an
example of something very
important and quite general.
Which was that locally optimal
decisions do not always lead
to a global optimums. So you
can't just repeatedly do the
apparently local thing
and expect to
necessarily get to it.
Now, as it happens with the
continuous knapsack problem as
we've formulated it,
greedy is good.
But let's look for a slight
variant of it, where greedy is
not so good.
And that's what's called the
zero-one knapsack problem.
This is basically a discrete
version of
the knapsack problem.
The formulation is that we have
n items and at every step
we have to either take
the whole item
or none of the item.
In the continuous problem, the
gold dust was assumed to be
infinitely small.
And so you could take as much
of it as you wanted.
Here it's as if you
had gold bricks.
You get to take the whole brick
or no brick at all.
Each item has a weight and a
value, and we're trying to
optimize it as before.
So let's look at an example of
a zero-one knapsack problem.
Again we'll go back
to our burglar.
So the burglar breaks into the
house and finds the following
items available.
And you'll see in your handout
a list of items and their
value and how much,
what they weight.
Finds a watch, a nice Bose
radio, a beautiful Tiffany
vase, and a large
velvet Elvis.
And now this burglar finds, in
fact, two of each of those.
Person is a real velvet Elvis
fan and needed two
copies of this one.
Alright, and now he's trying
to decide what to take.
Well if the knapsack were large
enough the thief would
take it all and run, but let's
assume that it can only hold
eight pounds, as before.
And therefore the thief
has choices to make.
Well, there are three types of
thieves I want to consider:
the greedy thief, the
slow thief, and you.
We'll start with the
greedy thief.
Well, the greedy thief follows
the greedy algorithm.
What do you get if you follow
the greedy algorithm?
What's the first thing
the thief does?
Takes the most valuable item,
which is a watch.
And then what does
he do after that?
Takes another watch.
And then?
Pardon?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: And then?
PROFESSOR: No.
Not unless he wants to break
the vase into little pieces
and stuff it in the corners.
The backpack is now
full, right?
There's no more room.
So the greedy thief take
that and leaves.
But it's not an optimal
solution.
What should the thief
have done?
What's the best thing
you can do?
Instead of taking that
one vase, the thief
could take two radios.
And get more value.
So the greedy thief, in some
sense, gets the wrong answer.
But maybe isn't so dumb.
While greedy algorithms are not
guaranteed to get you the
right answer all the
time, they're often
very good to use.
And what they're good about is,
they're easy to implement.
And they're fast to run.
You can imagine coding
the solution up
and it's pretty easy.
And when it runs, it's pretty
fast. Just takes the most
valuable, the next most
valuable, I'm done.
And the thief leaves,
and is gone.
So that's a good thing.
On the other hand, it's often
the case in the world that
that's not good enough.
And we're not looking for an OK
solution, but we're looking
for the best solution.
Optimal means best. And that's
what the slow thief does.
So the slow thief thinks
the following.
Well, what I'll do is I'll
put stuff in the
backpack until it's full.
I'll compute its value.
Then I'll empty the backpack
out, put another combination
of stuff compute its value,
try all possible ways of
filling up the backpack, and
then when I'm done, I'll know
which was the best. And that's
the one I'll do.
So he's packing and unpacking,
packing and unpacking, trying
all possible combinations of
objects that will obey the
constraint.
And then choosing the winner.
Well, this is like an algorithm
we've seen before.
It's not greedy.
What is this?
What category of algorithm
is that?
Somebody?
Louder?
STUDENT: Brute force.
PROFESSOR: Brute force,
exhaustive
enumeration, exactly.
We're exhausting all
possibilities.
And then choosing the winner.
Well, that's what the
slow thief tried.
Unfortunately it took so long
that before he finished the
owner returned home, called the
police and the thief ended
up in jail.
It happens.
Fortunately, while sitting in
jail awaiting trial, the slow
thief decided to figure
what was wrong.
And, amazingly enough, he
had studied mathematics.
And had a blackboard
in the cell.
So he was able to work it out.
So he first said, well, let me
try and figure out what I was
really doing and why
it took so long.
So first, let's think about what
was the function the slow
thief was attempting
to maximize.
The summation, from i equals 1
to n, where n is the number of
items, so I might label watch
1-0, watch 2-2, I don't care
that they're both watches.
They're two separate items.
And then what I want to
maximize is the sum of the price
of item i times whether
or not I took x i.
So think of x as a vector
of 0's and 1's.
Hence the name of the problem.
If I'm going to keep that item,
item i, if I'm going to
take it, I give it a 1.
If I'm not going to take
it I give it a 0.
And so I just take the value of
that item times whether or
not it's 0 or 1.
So my goal here is to choose x
such that this is maximized.
Choose x such that that function
is maximized, subject
to a constraint.
And the constraint, is it the
sum from 1 to n of the weight
of the item, times x i, is less
than or equal to c, the
maximum weight I'm allowed
to put in my backpack.
In this case it was eight.
So now I have a nice, tidy
mathematical formulation of
the problem.
And that's often the first step
in problem reduction.
Is to go from a problem that has
a bunch of words, and try
and write it down as a nice,
tight mathematical
formulation.
So now I know the formulation
is to find x, the vector x,
such that this constraint
is obeyed and
this function is maximized.
That make sense to everybody?
Any questions about that?
Great.
So as the thief had thought,
we can clearly solve this
problem by generating all
possible values of x and
seeing which one solves
this problem.
But now the thief started
scratching his head and said,
well, how many possible
values of x are there?
Well, how can we think
about that?
Well, a nice way to think
about that is to
say, I've got a vector.
So there's the vector with
eight 0's in it.
Three, four, five, six,
seven, eight.
Indicating I didn't take
any of the items.
There's the vector, and again
you'll see this in your
handout, says I only took
the first item.
There's the one that says I
only took the second item.
There's the one that says
I took the first
and the second item.
And at the last,
I have all 1's.
This series look like anything
familiar to you?
These are binary
numbers, right?
Eight digit binary numbers.
Zero, one, two, three.
What's the biggest number
I can represent
with eight of these?
Somebody?
Well, suppose we had
decimal numbers.
And I said I'm giving you
three decimal digits.
What's the biggest number you
can represent with three
decimal digits?
Pardon?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
Which is roughly what?
10 to the?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
Yes.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
Exactly right.
So, in this case it's
2 to the 8th.
Because I have eight digits.
But exactly right.
More generally, it's
2 to the n.
Where n is the number of
possible items I have to
choose from.
Well, now that we've figured
that out, what we're seeing is
that the brute force algorithm
is exponential.
In the number of items we
have to choose from.
Not in the number that we take,
but the number we have
to think about taking.
Exponential growth
is a scary thing.
So now we can look at
these two graphs,
look at the top one.
So there, we've compared n
squared, quadratic growth,
which by the way Professor
Grimson told you was bad, to,
really bad, which is
exponential growth.
And in fact, if you look at
the top figure it looks as
exponential or, quadratic isn't
even growing at all.
You see how really fast
exponential growth is?
You get to fifteen items and
we're up at seventy thousand
already and counting.
The bottom graph has exactly
the same data.
But what I've done is, I've use
the logarithmic y-axis.
Later in the term, we'll spend
quite a lot of time talking
about how do we visualize
data.
How do we make sense of data.
I've done that because you can
see here that the quadratic
one is actually growing.
It's just growing a
lot more slowly.
So the moral here
is simple one.
Exponential algorithms are
typically not useful. n does
not have to get very big for
exponential to fail.
Now, imagine that you're trying
to pack a ship and
you've got ten thousand
items to choose from.
2 to the 10,000 is a
really big number.
So what we see immediately,
and the slow thief decided
just before being incarcerated
for years and years, was that
it wasn't possible to
do it that way.
He threw up his hands and
said, it's an unsolvable
problem, I should have been
greedy, there's no
good way to do this.
That gets us to the
smart thief.
Why is this thief smart?
Because she took 600.
And she learned that in fact
there is a good way to solve
this problem.
And that's what we're going
to talk about next.
And that's something called
dynamic programming.
A lot of people think this is
a really hard and fancy
concept, and they teach in
advanced algorithms classes.
And they do, but in fact
as you'll see it's
really pretty simple.
A word of warning.
Don't try and figure out
why it's called dynamic
programming.
It makes no sense at all.
It was invented by a
mathematician called Bellman.
And he was at the time being
paid by the Defense Department
to work on something else.
And he didn't want them to
know what he was doing.
So he made up a name that he
was sure they would have no
clue what it meant.
Unfortunately, we now have
lived with it forever, so
don't think of it as actually
being anything dynamic
particularly.
It's just a name.
It's very useful, and why we
spend time on it for solving a
broad range of problems that
on their surface are
exponentially difficult.
And, in fact, getting very
fast solutions to them.
The key thing in dynamic
programming, and we'll return
to both of these, is you're
looking for a situation where
there are overlapping
sub-problems and what's called
optimal substructure.
Don't expect to know what
these mean yet.
Hopefully by the end of the day,
Tuesday, they will both
make great sense to you.
Let's first look at
the overlapping
sub-problems example.
You have on your handout,
a recursive
implementation of Fibonacci.
Which we've seen before.
What I've done is I've augmented
it with this global
called num calls just so I can
keep track of how many times
it gets called.
And let's see what happens
if we call fib of 5.
Well, quite a few steps.
What's the thing that you notice
about this output?
There's something here that
should tip us off that maybe
we're not doing this the most
efficient way possible.
I called fib with 5 and then
it calls it with 4.
And then that call
calls fib with 3.
So I'm doing 4, 3, 2, 2, 1, 0.
And I'm doing 1, 2.
Well, what we see is I'm calling
fib a lot of times
with the same argument.
And it makes sense.
Because I start with fib of 5,
and then I have to do fib of 4
and fib of 3.
Well, fib of 4 is going to also
have to do a fib of 3 and
a fib of 2 and a fib of
1, and a fib of 0.
And then the fib of 3 is going
to do a fib of 2 and a fib of
1 and a fib of 0.
And so I'm doing the same thing
over and over again.
That's because I have what
are called overlapping
sub-problems. I have used divide
and conquer, as we seen
before, to recursively break it
into smaller problems. But
the smaller problem of fib of
4 and the smaller problem of
fib of 3 overlap with
each other.
And that leads to a lot of
redundant computation.
And I've done fib of 5, which
is a small number.
If we look at some other things,
for example, let's get
rid of this.
Let's try see fib of 10.
Well, there's a reason I chose
10 rather than, say, 20.
Here fib got called 177 times.
Roughly speaking, the analysis
of fib is actually quite
complex, of a recursive fib.
And I won't go through it, but
what you can see is it's more
or less, it is in fact,
exponential.
But it's not 2 to
the something.
It's a more complicated thing.
But it grows quite quickly.
And the reason it does is
because of this overlapping.
On Tuesday we'll talk about a
different way to implement
Fibonacci, where the growth will
be much less dramatic.
Thank you.